everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we are in round 2
of our coverage of the 2018 canada's
tournament and round 1 had some
fireworks a lot of people expected
players to come out not be overly
aggressive and try to push for wins
because there are 14 rounds last thing
you want to do is try an extremely
aggressive line and then end up on
losing into bats knowing that there's so
many strong players we've just seen that
over time in high-level competition but
of the four matches three of those we
had wins with Vladimir Kramnik we had
check it and then Fabiano Caruana all
getting victories in round 1 and round 2
today we have two of the losers from
those matches alexander gouda shook who
lost to Vladimir Kramnik and Wesley so
who lost to Fabiana Carlotta
judiciary's gonna be playing the white
pieces so is gonna be playing the black
pieces for the second day in a row both
these players looking to get back on
track as they did get beat in round one
so we're go ahead and get started
without and they're gonna ship pawn to
e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and then
a bishop here to b5 getting into the Rui
Lopez now pawn to a6 the mainline Bishop
coming back here to a4 Knight f6 castle
on the King side and then Bishop to e7
this is the close defense the mainline
in the RAI Lopez pawn to d3 though is
someone an unusual move usually from
white we're seeing rook here to e1 or
even Knight to c3 is pretty popular as
well but ponta to d3 doesn't see a lot
of play interesting that fellow
countryman Peter Spindler actually did a
series on pawn to d3 so not sure if
Peter Svidler was talking to Alexander
gonna show telling him that hey you
should actually try this pawn to d3 move
out in at the right Lopez close defense
but that's exactly what we see here so
after pawn to d3 pawn to d5 kicking the
bishop back here to b3 pawn d6
solidifying the pawn chain so both sides
very very similar in their pawn
structures this is why it's called a
closed defense really just locking down
the center of the board not an open game
at all pawn to c3 another inch
interesting move from white you know the
approach from Ganesha kids to play in
opening that that Wesley so is not super
familiar with a pawn to c3 is the move
castle on the King side and then pawn to
h3 and this is pawn age three usually
what we see instead of pawn to c3 just
pawn age three stopping the knight
coming down here or even the bishop
coming down pinning down the knight to
the Queen here on a d1 and then just
waiting to see what black does from here
which is usually gonna be cast on the
King side followed by rook to e1 for
whites but in the game we see that pawn
to c3 Castle and then pawn here to h3
Bishop to be 7 this is finkin and the
bishop over here to the Queen side of
the board getting it involved to attack
these light squares in the center of the
board are really trying to put pressure
on these light squares and the night to
a d2 protecting the night here on f3 as
well as if it needs to push forward with
pawn to c4 try to defend the center of
the board he can do that as well
rook to e8 and this is interesting any
time your opponent moves you always want
to be looking at what did they give up
were they defending a particular piece
you know was do you have two pieces
attacking a square and then all of a
sudden they have one after they move it
and it was a mistake all of a sudden you
can see that this Bishop here on b3 is
attacking the square here on f7 the rook
and the King we're both defending it now
that the rook has moved only the King is
defending this right here so we see
Alexander gadot community play Knight to
g5 the night and and the bishop are both
attacking this pawn a critical Square
early on especially in the RAI Lopez
when we get into the close defense and
so we see Wesley so decide to go and
just bring his rook back here to f8 so
it's not real clear if the knight on g5
gives white really that significant
advantage but white is up a move in the
game because now rook over here to e1
and white theoretically is move twice is
black has wasted two moves rook here t8
and then back to f8 pawn to d5 suppose
lesotho decides to go ahead and break up
the center of the board we do see an
exchange in the center of the board and
then Knight to f3 now
Queen to d7 always you know when you
look at this and say okay we have this
pawn here on e5 both the Knights and the
rook here on a1 are attacking this and
only the night here on c6 is defending
this something seems to be going on here
why why would they allow that the issue
would be is after the the Queen comes
down here to d7 not defending this
square the knight can't just take the
material so if we see Knight takes on e5
Knight recaptures rook takes the key
move here would be pawn to f6 attacking
both the knight and the rook one of
these pieces is gonna fall if white
decides I'll just go ahead and gobble up
some material here rook takes on e7
Queen takes Knight it's just gonna fall
back to e4 White's gonna lose material
in that exchange so not gonna be looking
to do that so after Queen to d7 instead
of taking the pawn that maybe looks like
it is undefended by more than one piece
white decides to go and play pawn to d4
black decides to take that pawn there on
d4 and then Ganesha corresponds breathe
recapturing here on d4 and white hasn't
isolated pawn in at the center of d4 now
the way Ganesha is playing it does look
like he's confident in this particular
line but it does give Wesley so
something to plan around he can start to
attack this knowing that why it's gonna
have to spend all of his material
defending this instead of using his
pawns one thing that you'll notice in
this position is that the board has
completely opened up while we started
out with the rise lobe right Lopes
closed open all of a sudden we have the
pawns coming off the board we have both
sides with all of their major and minor
pieces so there could definitely be
fireworks as both sides are really
looking to stay aggressive in the game
pond h6 forces the knight to come back
here to e4 rook to EA so both sides try
to activate as much material as possible
Bishop to d2 white really wants to bring
his rook here to c1 there's not a lot of
great squares for the bishop doesn't
want to come here to g5 that would be a
terrible move just lose the bishop and
if it comes here to f4 or e3 as well
both of those squares the knight could
off the board anytime you have an open
boart's that you really wants your
bishops on the board they can just
control so much more the board than a
knight can in this position so not
looking to do that someone said we see
Bishop here to d2 it really just is for
the rook to come here to see one so the
white can really control these semi open
files and open files in the center of
the board and I back here to f6 rook to
c1 we do see an exchange and then the
rook up here to e4 if we come back and
say okay that the knight takes here on
e4 but why would the knight just not
take here on a d4 this is a poison pawn
it may look like it is okay to take but
it's actually not while yes it is true
that the knight could take knight
recaptures and then the Queen takes it
does look like you know black is good in
this position the problem is that if the
knight were to take here then white can
actually come up here and take on f7 now
there's a few moves as far as how black
could continue you can probably see
right away if the King takes here on f7
then we have a fork Knight to e5 check
this is pretty much gonna just get a
resignation from black the Queen is
going to fall if we see instead the King
does not take oh so he has a few other
options you could play King to h7 okay
here's where things get you know pretty
interesting I would say complicated to
find for white but at the highest level
they could absolutely find this line
Knight to a g5 and then you know what is
black do from here it's gonna be bad if
he takes with pawn on to g5 tonight it's
gonna come up here to f6 check after the
pawn takes Queen to h5 and it's gonna be
a quick death march up here for a
checkmate now if we come back and say
what if the the pod doesn't take that
okay well then we could just see the the
King come back here to h8 doesn't have a
lot of good options here Knight takes
here on f6 after the pawn takes Queen up
here to h5 things are going to get very
very bad as we see this Queen getting
ready to take here on h6 maybe the
knight comes to f5 stopping the the
Queen
coming from here but then queen up here
to g6 it's now attacking this night all
of a sudden the rook can get involved
into the game
maybe the pawn takes rook takes here on
e7 after the queen takes bishop to c3
and this this is so tough because the
bishop coming here is another for kit if
the Queen moves though if it's not
defending the square then all of a
sudden it is going to be mate so there's
no great way for black to really respond
to this if he tries to try something
with his rook maybe rook to g8 attacking
white as much as possible yes why could
just take this if you wanted to but then
that fort comes into play so all in all
black is going to end up losing in this
situation
Knight to d4 not a good play so that we
don't see that from Wesley so instead
Knight takes on e4 and then rook takes
on e4 recaptures bishop here to f5
attacking this isolated pawn we now have
the Knights the bishop and the Queen all
attacking is isolated pawn it also opens
up the door for this rook on e8 to
control this open file really countering
this rook here on e4 from Alexander
guard issue instead of trying to hold on
to the material here on d4 white goes on
the offensive you plays rook to G for
setting up the bishop taking here on h6
the pawn can't recapture because it is
being pinned down by the rook to the
King here so we see King tha this is
where I think Wesley so you know
missteps and freaks out a little bit by
the threat that white has a move like
pawn to h5 you know not too worried
about Bishop here to h6 you're just
gonna take that material here that's
pretty easy so why it's not gonna be
doing that it also forces rook to really
move and figure out where he's gonna go
with an attack yes it does extend the
material on the King side of the board
but you gotta do something you can't let
your opponent continue to attack you he
has so much material lined up at your
King side both his bishop you're lined
up here he has a rook bring over here to
g4 someone disrespectful I would just
try to kick that off with pawn to h5
another option will just be rook to d8
says yeah I don't really care if you
want to take this material right here
I have protection with my bishop on F
for the square on g7 that's fine I'm
gonna just get up on the center of the
board I have so much material lining up
here that's gonna be fine with me but in
the game Wesley so sees this and he
responds with King to h8 now Rick to c5
and you can see things getting pretty
aggressive on board here rook to the 8th
I think it's a little bit too late
and then Queens who see one so this rook
coming up here to c5 it's an outpost
move does allow the Queen to come over
here support it as well as support this
Bishop as well now the bishop could take
here and can't really be captured by the
pawn here on h6 because then the Queen
could come up here and that would be
checkmate it has the Queen here on age
six as well as the rook here on g4 so
now I'm going to be seeing that from
Wesley so so after the Queen's to c1
takes the pawn here on d4 that isolated
pawn Knight recaptures rook down here to
e4 trying to exchange that material but
we don't see an exchange right away rook
up here to c7 always want to get your
rook to your opponent's seventh rank if
you are playing as white just show many
attacks that you can have you can see
already attacking both the bishop and
the Queen Queen's gonna be forced to
move as well as attacking these pawns as
well Queen does come down here takes on
d4 Bishop to e3 forcing you know black
to respond rook over here takes on a g4
reducing exchange and now the Queen is
forced to move decides to come here to
e4 pawn up here to f3 Queen over here to
b4 and then the rook is free to take the
bishop here on at b7 so yes all of a
sudden we see on the board the black is
down a material he can gain back
material here he plays this Bishop down
here - B - so he does get one pawn back
but he is down a bishop if this move
does look odd to you because yeah I took
this pawn but the Queen can just take it
this is where a lot of players go wrong
in chess they may just decide let's go
ahead and take this material and this is
where I like to tell players that even
if you are behind black is clearly
behind an entire bishop going into the
in game
is very difficult to come back from now
this is an open game so many times black
can find a strong attack and y can
always make a mistake especially if
you're not at the highest level but one
thing that you can do especially if
you're black has play something like
Bishop to b2 just saying hey opponent
you should go ahead and take with your
queen right here this is actually a
drawing game because Queen to e1 check
there's no other move besides keen to h2
only optional move now Queen to h4 check
only move again is King back here to d1
and they could just do this and this
would end up being a draw so it doesn't
matter how much of advantage White has
on board this is going to end up being a
drawing game so don't fall into this
always be looking you know why would my
opponent do this and if I'm up in
material does my opponent have the
option to have a perpetual check they
would end up just drawing at the game so
we see Alexander go district play a
queen to f1 pawn here to f6 Queen to f2
bishop up here to e5 and both sides you
know really just trying to do anything
they can you know black side really
trying to find some attack white really
just trying to hold on he doesn't have
to force anything he has the much better
in game so all in all just needs to make
sure he does not make a mistake Bishop
comes back here to d6 pawn up here to g5
trying to exchange down if you're up in
material many times exchanging down
material just makes your advantage that
much more prominent in the game Creed
over here to e4 Queen up to f3 says hey
if you want exchanged on board that's
gonna be fine with me
Queen to be one Queen down f1 could have
also if you wanted to just play King to
f2 I think this is a great move as well
out there
there's no strong attack the black has
here just with his queen and he is
blocking off his rook here on D H really
get involved into the game but that's
okay instead of King to f2 we do see
Queen down here to f1 really just
telling his opponent hey let's just go
and exchange on board Queen to f2 to e4
Queen up here to f3 we do see a little
bit of song in
dance we don't want to see the threefold
repetition if you have that the same
board state three times it would be a
drawl so why it's not looking to do that
so now he plays the King to f2 which
probably the better move all in all
bishop down here to be for Queen to e2
Queen up here to e4 Queen f3 and now
King to g3 so same sort of situation
where don't want to have that the same
board state three times so plays King
here to g3 it's a pretty safe square you
know how does black really attack this
from here pawn takes King down here to
h2 Queen of to f5 sure work over here to
f7 this is being protected by the bishop
here on B 1 or B 3 and can't really
attack this Bishop here on b3 with any
of the material so that's always good
and if you look at it it's always nice
to see you know how White's setting this
up black has this one Bishop and it's on
a dark square so what's white doing he's
putting all of his important pieces on
light squares he has his Bishop es his
rook
he has his Queen here on light squares
he really just has his bishop and his
pawn here on dark squares but very very
easy to to figure that out and make sure
it doesn't make a mistake Queen up here
to g6 pawn takes Bishop up here to d6
check and then King to h3 and this this
is where that last dagger we're okay now
pretty much all my material is on the
light squares and then at the end of the
day there's just not much that black can
really do here so decides to go ahead
and resign
you know blacks in are gonna shake just
too much material in at the in game
especially with the bishop pair and just
putting so much pressure on his opponent
no way for Wesley to continue so
Wesley's though losing the the first two
games in the Candace tournament not the
start that he was looking for good issue
coming back strong after loss in the
first round so he's back on track will
be looking to to move up the the leader
ranks no one else won today
so everyone that won yesterday that had
a the full point they were only able to
get half a point today so good news
shook is only half the point behind and
he does have 12 rounds remaining but
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video we
do have 12 more rounds of coverage to go
through it has been an exciting
tournament already excited for the next
few weeks of chat so thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next video